well let's talk to a Bharat gopalaswami
he's a senior fellow at the observer
Research Foundation he joins us via
Skype from New Brunswick New Jersey
Bharat what do you make of a timing of
this announcement then by the Indian
government about updating the National
Population register I mean why now and
what's the thinking behind it I think
it's just for timing you know I don't
know what the thinking behind it this
and but it also sends mixed signals
but then the Prime Minister's in a way
launched his election campaign New Delhi
is going into a state election he
launched a campaign a couple of days ago
and he expressed his views about he was
in a way is trying to reassure but then
this announcement comes at the heels of
this whole citizenship amendment though
so you know it's at one level you trying
to reassure the public that it's not
discriminatory at the other level you're
trying to put your foot on the gas and
saying we're going to embark on such
endeavors so it is it's more timing
poorly judged and I think at many levels
it also I don't know if it's a confused
government or they do not know in which
direction that they want ahead but but
they're very clear about one thing is
very clear is that they're not going to
back off from the citizenship amendment
bill despite the protests yeah I've
given given given all the anger given
all the anger and deadly violence over
the citizenship law is this then how is
this likely to be seen as yet another
tool that will discriminate against
Muslims well I mean let's you know let's
rewind it to this summer right we
started with fish mayor then we have the
issue with the Supreme Court passed a
judgement of building a temple on the
disputed land and then when you come up
with as the National Register of
citizens in the Northeast
then you come on put the citizenship
omit them though then you know allocate
funding for the National Population
register so it's not one data point now
you know my critics might argue that
it's speculated these are five different
issues in five different directions but
there is a common element and there is a
common undertone about the
discrimination of Muslims that's why you
see I need to dangle that people coming
onto the streets and protesting like the
gentleman on your show said where are
their protests but you know but that's
not the point the protestors there are
protest
there is an international media there's
an outcry about this right so when you
couple all these things when you look
look at all these things in its entirety
there is a trajectory there is a curve
that you can plot in that curve
sometimes it's not in a good direction
yeah an in in a in a recent speech at a
rally New Delhi the Prime Minister
Narendra Modi tried to calm fears saying
look Muslims have got nothing to worry
about but the NPR will do will will no
doubt inflame tensions as you say and it
does send mixed signals doesn't it yeah
I mean you know like the Prime
Minister's the Prime Minister's words
and they are not essentially followed by
actions right I mean within two days you
have an NPR coming out so I mean it's
it's just - it's not comfortable it's if
I were sitting on the other side and if
you you know the I think there is plans
of the BJP
the ruling party reaching out to a
majority of people to reassure them in
articulating the abuse now wouldn't that
be a logical first time than allocating
funding for this and making a big
announcement for this so I worry that
that such steps might be too little too
late well the government wants to douse
tensions off that that's where they
should have proceeded yeah and just a
final point to you Bharati matter how
much does all of this undermine the
campaign goals and the ideology of the
BJP because they don't seem to be
addressing issues like the economy as
you say jobs and the crisis in the
farming community right there is a
gentleman who said you know those are
real issues why aren't you know okay if
I were if if the legislations were
passed alongside of those issues where
you know there was an onion crisis
people are not talking about the onion
crisis anymore there's a jobs crisis
people are not talking about the jobs
crisis anymore and the IMF just released
its report and you know the dangers of
in the Indian slowdown so those are
fundamental real issues and those are
going to affect the people and not and
not a divisive agenda like this but pala
Swami thank you very much indeed for
talking to Al Jazeera pleasure